we're going to go to Nigeria now where
Boza tinubu has been declared the winner
of the presidential elections electoral
commission that says the ruling party
beats 17 other candidates vying for the
top job let's go straight now to Harold
Matassa in Abuja what can you tell us
talk us through these final results if
you will
supporters of the governing APC party
are ecstatic their candidate is now
Nigeria's
president-elect he is a former Governor
he's a wealthy businessman and he's been
in politics for many many years here in
Nigeria during his campaign Trail he
said he's going to try and Tackle
Nigeria's economy with an unemployment
rate of more than 30 percent but it's
not going to be easy for him I mean this
country has a lot of challenges people
are dealing with cash shortages fuel
shortages the high costs of living but
he says he's going to try and build new
infrastructure he's going to put more
money into social welfare programs and
agriculture the second person who came
after him was a Tikka abubakar another
opposition leader and then Peter Obi
also an opposition neither are those
results have been coming out and they
came second and third this election was
marred by a lot of irregularities for
example delays of people voting some
people didn't even get to vote some
areas there was violence people they
have been saying throughout the past few
days that they want to have a chance to
vote again that seems that is not going
to happen well the key thing to wait and
see now is how the opposition parties
are going to react we need to watch
opposition strongholds like Lagos the
commercial Capital uh the South and the
south east where these opposition
leaders had a huge amount of support but
right now in areas where tinubu is
popular his supporters are busy
celebrating
and what might the reaction indeed be on
on the streets to this vote count result
in Abuja some opposition supporters
started protesting saying that they
thought the selection was a sham
calling on the Commissioners here to
stop releasing any results some of them
were even saying that elections should
be held all over again Commissioners
said that is not going to happen and
They carried on with the process so a
big concern for some people now is how
opposition support is going to react so
far there's been no open call from
opposition leaders for their supporters
to take to the streets but there's been
lots of frustration and agitation over
the past few days because these results
took too long to be announced According
to some people but right now here in the
Collision Center the shouting you can
hear are supporters for the governing
APC party happy that tinubu has been
declared president-elect okay for now
Hannah Montana in Abuja there for us
thank you